the president also promised people in
Iowa that Senate Republicans will fix
their health care problems I will have
just one insurer participating in next
year's Obamacare marketplace I hope
we're going to surprise you with a
really good plan you know I've been
talking about a plan with heart
I said add some money to it a plan with
heart but Obamacare is dead
later today Senate Republican leaders
will release the full text of their
health care bill to repeal and replace
the Affordable Care Act and chacorta's
is on Capitol Hill Nancy good morning
good morning the draft of this bill has
been kept virtually under lock and key
but will be revealed this morning in a
meeting for all Republican senators
here's what we know so far based on
Republican leaders and their
conversations with us and with aides
this Bill's about 200 pages it's called
a discussion draft because they can
still make changes to it based on
feedback from their members and like the
House bill it's going to do away with
large swathes of Obamacare including the
individual mandate and Obama cares taxes
but the Senate version would not cut
Medicaid as quickly as the House GOP
version would it will also keep more of
Obamacare protections in place for
people with pre-existing conditions than
the House bill would and the tax credits
in the Senate bill for people who are on
the individual market would be based on
income not on age like the House bill so
people who have less income would get
more assistance now one key piece of
data that we probably won't get today is
an independent analysis from the
Congressional Budget Office you'll
recall that the CBO projected that 23
million Americans would lose coverage
under the House bill so Republican
senators are going to want to see what
the CBO has to say before they decide
how to vote on this bill so Republican
leaders Gale are hoping that the CBO
weighs in by Monday at the latest
because they want to hold a vote next
week all right thank you very much Nancy